welcome back to glam unfiltered hosted
by me josh smith and today we are joined
by
the queen of reality television it's
gemma collins
josh i've been waiting to speak to you
for a long time
well babe we're here we're making it
happen and we're gonna get quite deep
today
aren't we okay which isn't necessarily
usually something everyone knows you for
because
i think that everyone has you out as
this
incredible persona that is the gc
with that idea of that persona why did
you feel like you had to kind of create
that character
in in yourself and did it kind of feel
like
you as a person wasn't enough or did you
feel like you had to add this extra
layer to yourself in a way
i'm just a very normal girl
and it's so weird because obviously
people think i live this extravagant
lifestyle
every day but actually i'm a country
girl
like i got so excited most people would
get excited about a new bag coming out
or a new fashion collection i got
excited to see conkers on the trees this
week
so it's like i'm a very homely sweet
like i am easily offended
i am vulnerable you know i do wear my
heart on my
sleeve and it's that's what makes it
probably
so difficult but the reason i immersed
myself
in the gc is because being in show
business
isn't the norm every day
you know i've discovered more than ever
recently
like i did realize there's so many
people that are jealous of me
people can be cruel it was samantha fez
actually that came up
she called me gc at filming once and i
was like the gc
sasha fierce yes this is gonna work yeah
because day today josh
i'm not the gc you know um
i'm really not the gc and it's probably
now more than ever i turned 40
this year and i think since doing my
show and i couldn't hide myself in
lockdown i had no error makeup i had no
choice
i have become more comfortable in
showing that side of me now i'm not sure
whether it comes from filming diva in
lockdown
um but i don't mind that people see me
waltz at all now because at the end of
the day
it's real life i think as well like
because what you're saying is
you are a normal girl you have these
vulnerabilities that every other
woman man human has as well and
you're also dealing with a time of
extreme scrutiny
and being under a magnifying glass your
own mental health your own mental
well-being
for you what has probably been the
hardest thing to mentally have to deal
with
behind the scenes while having the
spotlight going through breakups
is really hard when you're in the public
eye because the press
you know they're constantly i don't know
what it is they tag you in stories with
your ex
and it's you know at the end of the day
your heart's breaking just like there
would be if you're going through
a breakup and then you've constantly got
to see it on the daily mail or you know
various magazines or papers
every problem that everyone goes through
listen don't get me wrong financially
you know i think i'm comfortable
and probably i don't have that pressure
like someone else
um but again i've worked for that and i
have been very lucky but
you know my sink's leaking today i've
got to get a plumber in
um what else happened to me oh yeah my
freezer
i must have left it open last night i
was defrosting the freezer
but it was so cold i put the oven on
open the oven door open the freezer dock
and i was trying to defrost the freezer
that way
with the other day ah
with the oven i said i was trying to
defrost the freezer
so this is what i'm saying like doesn't
matter how glamorous my day
is you are not immune to daily
situations
and being so scrutinized like i think
i've always done a good job
of not kind of giving two hoots yeah and
i don't really like i am gonna mess up
i am gonna fudge up sometimes and it is
really hard because the more famous you
get you know your management team so you
can't be seen with that one you can't
hang about with that one that one's got
a bad reputation don't go near them
and it's kind of like oh it's a lot of
pressure i'm being honest there's also a
lot of haters in this world as well
which is and
it should all be a lot kinder to each
other but for you
what would still be something triggering
or what would be something
triggering that would be said about you
or you'd see from trolls
that would really affect you and how
have you learned to move past that what
would still even get you now
from trolls well as well there are
obviously triggering situations that can
happen
but um for me i have therapy every week
i think it's really positive because
even though i'm a really strong person
i found the whole covered lockdown
restrictive thing
quite a lot to deal with because i'm a
free spirit
i like to go out and about i like to be
free i don't like any kind of
restriction
what therapy has taught me because it
can hurt you and
do you know the really sad thing about
it josh she's like you could be doing
your makeup or you could be a friend's
birthday even
in the best celebration but you almost
have ptsd from it
because the memory of someone saying
something cool to you
i mean i can remember someone said
you're too fat we won't work with you
this clothing brand yeah
and they didn't tell me that i remember
this agent at the time told me it
well sorry [ __ ] look at me now um
and yeah yeah person knows who she is
and having my therapy i
obviously dealt with a lot of the
trolling um
and actually now if i'm being honest i
wish the trolls well
because if they live with that anger
that nastiness inside them josh
that's so sad for them i'm free of it
i'm free of pain i'm free of anger
everyone's entitled to be on their
journey in life whether that's me
or kim down the road with regards to the
trolls
i send them love and i wish them well
and i don't even mean that sarcastically
like
you know i can remember being at an
airport recently and this guy was
kept trying to take a picture and we was
filming he just started chanting fatty
fatty fatty and i'm like huh
who behaves like this and he thought it
was bothering me but
it wasn't because i've heard it all
before yeah
um and i just thought gosh how awful
that
you live with this feeling inside of you
and
sent him love and wished him well
mentally you know not got time for bad
karma
um or nothing bad in my oric field i'm
not interested
you're probably actually arguably the
most famous plus sized woman in the uk
which is
english for you well isn't it nice that
i can be me
and people start accepting me for me
because to be honest all the talk about
my weight in this
it does get on my nerves um i saw a
headline today gemma collins gained four
pounds eat in tiger loaf bread and
butter
you know i've been honest and i said in
lockdown
although it was amazing for me in the
end but
there was times where i tucked into the
tiger life josh
like everyone does but it becomes a
major headline but
that's what people want to read makeup
breakups weight loss weight gain it's a
big seller
yeah and you have to remember what we're
working is in
is an industry but i can remove myself
from that now and
you know everyone can have a good good
run on a diet
and you can slip off the bandwagon you
know
self-shaming self-loathing self-hatred
is not good for anybody you know i even
had someone say to me the other day
which i found
so hurtful and offensive
and i know the person and i pulled them
up and i don't know if they think they
was being
fun brash or they thought i was being
clever but they went to me do you still
hang out with all your gays
now how disgusting is that
and i was so shocked by that comment
because one
why are you so interested in who i'm
hanging out with
and two do you know how awful
that is for someone and i felt like i
was almost being
picked on for having such amazing gay
friends
let there just be love and peace let
everyone be free like john lennon
yoco oh no i'm i'm just so big on all of
that now
and as long as i'm not hurting you don't
worry about who i'm hanging
out with don't charge everyone must stop
judging and if you know and even the
press to a certain point if i put on
four pound let it go
putting stone and i need to be carried
out my house
by air ambulance maybe let's talk about
it but
i don't think people still realize the
damages that it can affect
people and we should just all be a lot
kinder
i'm really realizing that now myself as
well
like you can give someone really good
advice and
and help them and but you just cannot
go around picking on people left right
and center because it can have
detrimental effects
it's so obvious as well because when you
were just talking about that just then
like
it hurt me you're getting upset it was
hurting you and like hurt me
like why are you worried about what
friends i'm hanging around with and
i hope that person hears this interview
and i'll never name them
and i'll never shame them i just hope
that they learn from it because it
really upset me and i found it offensive
so i think everyone's just got to be a
bit mindful and everyone is extra
sensitive at the minute even me
like to be honest i'm a night owl so
when the 10 o'clock curfew come in
i'm not at that age where i want to be
having a spaghetti bolognese at seven
o'clock
and settling down for the evening with
the electric blanket on josh
i need to be out in the banks i know
i just for me i found it a bit i'm gonna
be honest we all know i'm claustrophobic
i found it claustrophobic i didn't like
it when lockdown first started
oh my god it affected me like i don't
know
anyone that just breezed through it i
was like huh
my life's stopping i get all the reasons
it stopped
and i was happy to be on board with all
of them reasons
but i'd be lying to you you know if it
didn't give me i've never really been an
anxiety sufferer
um but in the pandemic i definitely
definitely
suffered from it um i can control it now
given everything that you've been
through and the struggles you've gone
through mentally
and with your body image and everything
that's you've gone through if you could
go back
to a time your life and be a friend to
yourself
at a particular occasion when would it
have been
and what would you have said to you i
probably would have took myself back to
about five years old
and if i was the little girl talking to
me now i would have said be kind to
yourself
because i do think we are all so hard on
ourselves
and we put a lot of pressure on
ourselves and i'm listening to that
little girl now and
it's like if i if i need to rest i rest
and if i've got a really busy day at
work i like
find my inner strength when i do it and
i've also
found the power in saying no to people
and so
freeing isn't it yes like i get hundreds
of requests every day can you promote
my friend's business my daughter's
business on top of that i get
hundreds of requests can you do a video
message on top of that
i get hundreds of other things then i've
got work emails i'm just one person
and simply the answer is no
we need to be more accepting of the word
no
100 percent and that is a great and josh
i want you to use that a lot more this
week honey babes i'll be serving up
those noses i'll be destiny's child
no all about it no no no no no no no
yes yes yes josh i love you thank you so
much
so thank you for the glamour readers or
viewers i don't know how they're going
to be watching this but
juicy love and learn to say no
bye babe bye josh